[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du money mais dans le jura louent dans
les bottes je lis moi de
voir la maison des émotions mais c'est
l'endroit qu'on avait choisi pour vivre
puis landreau ont ils pu
conférer dit lalonde s'installe dans le
quartier limoilou à québec en 2010 c'est
le début d'un projet de vie elle veut
s'ancrer dans le quartier avec sa
famille dès les premiers temps elle est
incommodé par une poussière différente
de ce qu'elle a connu dans d'autres
quartiers
à l'automne 2012 les choses prennent une
tournure inquiétante
que je sorte sur le balcon et j'ai
remarqué une fine pellicule de poussière
avec une coloration comme ça on en avait
toujours le may avait vraiment une fille
une coloration rose et rouge
des analyses vont révéler qu'il s'agit
d' oxydes de fer il provient du port de
québec tout à côté mais il ya autre
chose dans la poussière plusieurs métaux
lourds dont du nickel encore une fois le
port est pointé du doigt
[Musique]
véronique lalande se bat depuis 10 ans
pour la qualité de l'air à limoilou elle
a mené deux recours collectifs
inquiète pour sa santé elle a fini par
quitter le quartier mais ces jours ci
elle est aussi active que jamais
le 5 avril le ministère de
l'environnement du québec a annoncé
qu'il allait assouplir la norme sur le
nickel dans l'être
la déflexion somme la norme ni quelle
était l'origine
d'acteurs économiques que c'est ce qui a
déclenché la réflexion qui a été initiée
en 2000 ce
[Applaudissements]
temps hors du québec ou nunavik la
société blême croit au père une mine de
nickel
laminoir le minerai subi une première
transformation sur place avant d'être
envoyé au port de québec à bord d'un
brise glace
au port le concentré de nickel et
transférés à bord de trains plus amener
jusqu à sudbury en ontario pour subir
une deuxième transformation
la maxe de nickel revient de nouveau au
port de québec elle est chargée à bord
d'un navire plus envoyer vers une
affinerie en norvège
quand le vent souffle du nord-est les
poussières du port de québec sont
entraînés vers limoges
donc à la rafale de vins en provenance
des opérations portuaires s'ouvre vers
la station d'où son prix les
échantillons les taux peuvent être très
très très très élevé
entre le port et le vieux limoilou se
trouve une station d'échantillonnage
d'air opéré par le ministère de
l'environnement
d'après le ministère la concentration de
nickel mesurer à la station a dépassé la
norme 7 % du temps en 2020 en 2021 ce
sont 10 % des échantillons qui
excédaient la norme
[Musique]
selon le gouvernement cette norme était
trop stricte elle nuisait à l'industrie
du nickel dont les activités sont
essentiels à la fabrication de batteries
pour les véhicules électriques
le gouvernement a calculé qu'on pouvait
assouplir la norme sans mettre en danger
la santé des citoyens
actuellement la norme est fixé à 14
nanogrammes de nickel par mètre cube
d'air sur une période de 24 heures
la nouvelle norme permettra d'atteindre
70 nanogrammes par mètre cube sur 24
heures c'est cinq fois plus
à cette norme qui vise à contrôler des
pics occasionnels on ajoutera une norme
annuel
sur une année la concentration moyenne
de nickel dans l'air ne pourra pas
dépasser 20 nanogrammes par mètre cube
les résidents de limoilou sont en colère
nous ça fait dix ans qu'on dit
donnez-nous à l'heure de qualité mettez
en place des mesures qui vont assainir
notre ère et en lieu et place eh bien on
a un gouvernement que nous humains on
voit ouvrir la porte à plus de pollution
en moyenne les résidents limoilou vie
cinq années de moi que des habitants de
la haute ville de québec leurs revenus
sont moins élevés le tabagisme est plus
répandue et l'asthme plus fréquents
la norme de nickel aussi c'est une
indication claire que le gouvernement ne
semble pas intéressé à agir pour
amenuiser les inégalités sociales en
santé et dans un contexte où pourtant et
ça c'est selon santé canada la pollution
atmosphérique c'est le toit révisé
pour établir la nouvelle norme le
gouvernement s'appuie sur les rapports
de quatre experts dont celui de la
toxicologue michel bouchât
l'évaluation qui a été fait c'est ton
meilleur des connaissances en fonction
des données de la littérature en
utilisant mon expertise et celle de mon
équipe le mandat confié à michel
bouchard consistait à regarder sur
quelles études scientifiques se sont
basés les grands organismes
gouvernementaux comme l'union européenne
pour fixer leurs propres normes sur le
nickel
on a regardé l'ensemble des valeurs qui
ont regardé vers quel consensus global
ségo organismes gouvernementaux arrivé
en termes de valeur
dans son rapport remis au gouvernement
michel bouchard souligne que la france
et la norvège utilise la valeur limite
moyenne annuelle proposée par l'union
européenne de 20 nano grammes par mètre
cube
l'ontario a aussi retenu la valeur
limite de l'union européenne
cette norme de vin nanogrammes par mètre
cube se base sur des études d'une hache
of pharmacology programme mené chez des
souris on a appliqué des facteurs
d'incertitude pour l'adapter aux humains
selon la toxicologue avec une moyenne
annuelle de fin à nos grammes par mètre
cube on devrait prévenir les effets
inflammatoires et cancérogènes unique
elle
dans son rapport michel bouchard suggère
aussi de ne pas dépasser 49 grammes par
mètre cube au cours d'une seule journée
pour protéger les personnes les plus
sensibles
le gouvernement a opté pour 70
nanogrammes par mètre cube
la toxicologue est d'accord à condition
que ces pics soit isolé dans le temps ou
pas que j'ai cependant d'un journée
suite par exemple absolument pas
véronique lalande a passé des heures
avec son conjoint a décortiqué le
rapport de la toxicologue ce qu'on lui
reproche c'est d'être tombé dans le
piège vernement et de l'industrie qui
voulaient se coller aux normes
européennes c'est un peu seul énorme ont
choisi la cible qu'on veut attendez on
retrouve une documentation va trouver
une littérature qui soutient cette cible
le il n'y a pas un choix des études qui
ont été faits spécifiquement par notre
équipe on a regardé l'ensemble des
études qui ont été utilisés par ces
grands organistes là et les études qui
ont servi de base pour établir les
normes et les valeurs guident
les attaques contre la toxicologue sont
nombreuses
par exemple on fait valoir que la norme
annuelle de 20 nano grammes par mètre
cube retenu par l'europe réponse sur les
effets respiratoires du sulfate de
nickel dans l'air de limoilou on trouve
une molécule différente de la pente en
titre le sulfure de nickel et de faire
dans notre rapport en fait ce qu'on dit
c'est que le sulfate de nickel c'était
la forme la plus inflammatoires lorsque
on est exposé au nickel sous toutes ses
formes c'est l'effet inflammatoire qui
les fait critique elle admet néanmoins
que très peu d'études ont été réalisés
spécifiquement sur l'appontement dit
avec leur pantelant dit tu ailles une
étude à ma connaissance qui étaient
recensés mais si vous faites par exemple
un pot-de-vin de 1 go vous allez avoir
d'indiquer à trouver des études
le gouvernement a publié son projet de
règlement le 22 décembre dans la gazette
officielle
les citoyens avaient 60 jours pour
déposer leurs commentaires
plusieurs groupes se sont opposés à
l'assouplissement des normes des groupes
citoyens mais aussi des regroupements
professionnels
l'association québécoise des médecins
pour l'environnement et l'ordre des
chimistes du québec
michel bouchard reste inébranlable
aucun de ces groupes dit elle ne possède
son expertise aux toxicologie c'est
comme si on demande un nouveau
chirurgien de donner vos notes avis sur
un camp particulier versus ont un
médecin généraliste est ce que le
médecin généraliste va porter le même
regard que le neurochirurgien
la société guen quoi lui être
responsable des dépassements de la norme
de nickel dans limoilou
notre objectif c'est agonie sion et ç'a
toujours été notre but depuis qu'on n'a
pas réussi à québec nous avons visité
les installations de concours au port de
québec
le processus de transbordement du
minerai du navire jusqu'au train et sous
couvert à l'ouverture de la cale on
projette de la vapeur d'eau qui ont
empêché les poussières de sortir à l'air
libre le minerai est collecté avec un
bras mécanique puis acheminés avec un
système de convoyeurs fermé jusqu'à 1,2
d'entreposage le transfert à bord des
wagons se fait aussi sous couvert une
fois que le produit rendent à la liesse
et ils ne voient qu'une la lumière du
jour alors ses couverts destin alors
jusqu'à temps qu'ils arrivent à être
raffiné
et citoyens répondent que le procédé
peut être sous couvert sans être étanche
probable max ce sont des bonnes
pratiques est ce qu'elles sont toujours
toujours toujours appliqué ben moi je ne
sais pas il reproche aussi à glencore de
ne pas dévoiler les résultats de ces
stations d'échantillonnage d'air
le nickel souligne michel bouchard est
marginal par rapport aux autres
polluants qu'on retrouve dans l'air à
limoilou les particules fines issues du
transport dans l'air on va à bordeaux
composé qui sont présents à des
microgrammes par mètre cube
le nickel on est dans le nano grammes
par mètre cube un anneau g c'est mille
fois moins que microgrammes
ok c'est peut-être une fraction d une
fraction extrêmement symbolique est la
seule réponse que vous ne donnez après
dix vingt voire trente quarante ans de
mobilisation pour améliorer laquelle des
larcins rehaussement de la note oui
c'est vrai qu'il peut être autre chose
mais aussi ceux dont vous vous occupez
pas le 22 février dernier les dix huit
directions régionales de la santé
publique du québec se sont rangés
derrière les citoyens du maule où elle
estime que les données pour caractériser
le risque sont incomplètes elle rappelle
aussi l'importance de l'acceptabilité
sociale
le ministre de l'environnement benoit
charette a balayé leur avis du revers de
la main je faut remettre en question la
bonne foi des directions régionales mais
le travail qui est ici depuis quelques
années ils ont été faits et validés par
la santé publique nationale et non pas
par les directions régionales
elle vous parle de créer un précédent
prochaine industrie qui pourrait faire
respecter nomme x pourrait venir voir le
ministère dire ben smith et là non parce
qu'on n'arrive pas à se conformer en
fait on fait avancer
les normes environnementales en fonction
de la connaissance scientifique je pense
qu'il faut que le gouvernement
reconnaisse que sa science est
incomplète et que à partir de cette
science non on ne peut pas justifier la
modification d'une norme à l'échelle
d'un quartier qui est déjà mise à mal
mise à risque et vulnérables comme
nîmois loup et donc que le gouvernement
doit reconnaître sa reculer et jiabao au
contraire on reconnaît qu'un problème on
va agir pour amorcer un processus
réparateur pour mettre en place des
solutions durables et pérennes pour
régler la situation de qualité de
l'avant quartier c'est ça qu'on le lui
demande au gouvernement finalement le
gouvernement a statué la nouvelle norme
entrera en vigueur le 28 avril prochain
[Musique]
bernier que lalonde n'habite plus
limoilou depuis cinq ans mais elle n'a
pas l'intention de laisser tomber le
quartier
tout le monde au québec a le droit de
respirer un air sain on y croit
profondément donc on continue d'investir
parce qu'on pense qu'on a la capacité de
le faire on a des connaissances pour le
faire parce qu'on reste convaincu que
c'est la chose à faire ce que la chose
juste